The answer is the Handshake Protocol
That needs to use asymmetric cryptography to do authentication.
If we want to do authentication without starting from a shared key--
which, if we’re talking about a web browser and a client, we don’t have--
that always require some kind of asymmetric cryptography.
That’s what the Handshake Protocol uses.
It uses a combination of asymmetric and symmetric crypto.
The record protocol only uses symmetric encryption.
The reason for that is that we’ve established a session key by the end of the handshake.
Now we can use symmetric encryption which is much faster for encrypting all the content of pages.